are you talking to us sweetie I'm
talking to anybody who will listen we
should have just called this video the
many voices of Nick Kroll yeah okay that
sounds like a good deal however we are
going to sneak Andrew glauverman and all
your other favorites in here too so
don't you worry number one Nick plays
Nick shocker while Nick is the closest
to Kroll's original voice and a lot of
ways Nikki is really is me it's still a
little different because Nick is a kid
he's a little more up here he has far
more where that came from I think I
voice now between the two shows around
40 voices what's weird is having
multiple voices of his own holding a
conversation honestly you're making me
look bad you're making me look back
number two John only goes a little bit
red when he talks about his role on Big
Mouth John Mulaney a disgusting human
being how dare you how dare you assume
but I don't have rings John Mulaney just
wants to emphasize that that Andrew is a
character well Jon plays the most
irritating role on the show with
um Gusto and a whole lot of humility to
make some of those sounds in the booth
while recording some of his more
intimate moments they'll say like can
you give us just a half he mostly sticks
to playing Andrew but he also played
Detective Flores and a few offshoots of
himself him as a robot him in the future
wow that's a lot of information number
three and now for everyone's favorite
hormone monster we didn't know it was
Nick Kroll he's getting fun and loose
and
he's gonna chew he also had to have a
slightly older quality to him too hey
Rick what are we doing in this afternoon
what language is that
number four ao's brought a new life to
Missy but the voice change is subtle
because she's a pro AOA debris has been
playing Missy since the fourth season
but that isn't her beginning with big
mouth she was brought on as a writer
before taking over Missy she was played
by Jenny slate who stepped down you know
always basically like I should never
have been playing that part slate has
completely recorded season four but they
brought in AO to take over starting the
penultimate episode of the Season AO had
to at least kind of voice match with
Jenny but it didn't need to be perfect
because AO needed to embody this
character as her own her take on Missy
was found in the Callback audition
testing higher pitched voices lower
things that were closer to what had
originally been done by slate well they
finally landed on something that felt
right to AO sorry uh I'm busy and your
name is tell me now your name number
five the ghost in the Attic the honest
part of big mouth Jordan peel made the
movies us and get out some super intense
and groundbreaking horror stories so how
did he end up a voice on Big Mouth
playing the likes of everybody's
favorite ghost in the Attic Duke
Ellington that question answers itself
we think
happened to me once too he also voices
Jay's dog featuring ludicrous she was
super funny the ghost of Freddie Mercury
and Missy's dad oh and Brooklyn
nine-nine's Chelsea Peretti plays
Missy's mom why
such one
number six Maya is playing two mommies
now we guess Maya Rudolph plays our
favorite hormone monstrous Connie but
she also plays Nick burch's mommy Diane
Birch but actually she was only ever
meant to play Diane we're shook what has
gotten into you shook big forceful
gorgeous hairy monstery and roller
coastery are all words Maya would
describe Connie as she's a lot every
voice that she does on Big Mouth she
credits the creators for crafting them
so perfectly
um and we just laugh our butts off
number seven we could tell that the
ladybug and Coach Steve were both the
same person but they're both Nick what
come and visit me on the diaper barge
coach Steve is a recycled character
partly based on a character I did on
cultural named ref Jeff coach Steve has
evolved with time though when he first
started doing the voice he sounded he
was a little more like this you know but
now he's he's got a little more because
he's so dumb he's joyful what's that
saying ignorance is bliss he's so stupid
that he's happy number eight and now for
an impersonation of the thongs or the
actor who plays The Fonz oh look it's
the glauberman Fred Armisen plays
Elliott Birch I did the voice to sound
like Henry Winkler because he's very
warm in interviews you could hear a
little bit of New York in there now do
you think Elliot burch's animation is
based on Fred Armisen or do you think
it's based on Henry Winkler or maybe a
little bit of both number nine Rick and
Nick they were made for each other
Rick evolved to be even less
intelligible with time
and we realized there was kind of a
grooviness to him I blow myself I'm
a tandiway Newton plays the freakiest
hormone monstrous Mona [ __ ] you limp
nobody it's pretty fun in the recording
booth pretty cringe too they record
together to get that disgusting level of
chemistry cracking is bound to happen I
made him say it literally number 11 and
now for the other 30 plus characters we
could do an entry on Jesse Klein but
here's what you need to know she sounds
like herself and is a producer it's
never gonna happen Okay more Nick now I
don't think I'm a bad Mitten so far Nick
has voiced like 40 different characters
on Big Mouth come on what do you even
need from me Jimmy I'm not like a circus
puppet as well as Lola scumpy Kroll also
played the Dutch twins your confidence
is so appealing and so I know you
recently watched the Italian Stallion
Sylvester Stallone Nick is a man of many
vocal talents he's the king it's a good
game as far as adult or crude cartoons
go he was also involved in sausage party
and Captain Underpants
number 12 This Love Bug was a beautiful
addition to the show Brandon Kyle
Goodman was writing the scripts why are
we going to chase someone else when we
have such a talented voice right here a
new assignment Love Is in the Air he
brought such life to Walter the love bug
with that fantastic pop in his voice
people have aspirations to do more than
just right number 13. Jason J okay we
know one thing's for sure the guy is a
genius or insane Jason manzukas voices
Jay blitzerian hello Jay's father and
the Ghost of Socrates as long as you
live on one of the coasts random oh and
every character he seems to voice is
some version of a shirtless crazy person
so that's cool and we mean that in every
show that's not just limited to Big
Mouth number 14. we're taking a walk
down to human resources for a sec but
first Hugh Jackman played a phallus that
just looks like Hugh Jackman and only
had one line the ABS were non-negotiable
before he came on to human resources to
play the super sexy Aussie addiction
Angel Dante no no no they're harmless
it's just like putting a Ferrari engine
in your chest against type for him but
it's just his voice just pop he was
being his authentic self which he
doesn't always get opportunities to do
you he's talking in a way that we don't
normally hear Hugh Jackman talking he
was such a good sport about it because
at first the character was supposed to
be so wholesome he initially recorded
the character sounding like Wolverine we
don't want Wolverine we want Hugh
Jackman number 15. we are swooning over
our favorite fabulous Swan Andrew
Reynolds plays Matthew McDowell no
audition necessary Nick Kroll approached
Andrew for the role when he started
reading the scripts he found them so
filthy yet so sweet that he was sold he
gave a great insight into their early
covet days the cast was all recording
remotely thanks to those first few
months of the pandemic you have a leaf
in your hair big mouth is a messy gross
disgusting weird and oddly heartwarming
show that the cast put their heart into
evident from the actors taking on double
nope we promised ourselves we would
leave the toilet humor to the Geniuses
who write for Big Mouth are you as
impressed as we are by Nick Kroll's many
voices let us know in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things